double fatal crash in red rock has some
in the rental industry raising concerns
once again two men died while driving
the scenic loop early saturday joe
moeller spoke to the owner of the rental
company who says this really highlights
the needed change he is live here dean
martin and harman joining us now with a
bit more joe
brian just last week we were talking
about a fatal crash involving a rented
rolls royce well the crash on saturday
was involving a slingshot now if you
don't know what that is take a look
we're outside of exotic rent uh exotic
cars royalty exotic cars that is here in
vegas now these slingshots are these
three wheeled vehicles and you've
probably seen them around town they are
popular daily rentals now the owner of
royalty exotic cars says more needs to
be done
and meant to be that two-person
experience these slingshots are built
for fun it's open there's no doors but
saturday a joyride turned deadly this is
more considered a motorcycle than it is
a car two men from massachusetts died in
a crash while driving one through red
rock police say speed was a factor
houston crossta from royalty exotic cars
says just about all of the slingshots in
the valley are rentals he says the
deadly crashes have to be addressed i
don't want people to lose their lives
we've had a very good track record we
post we pride ourselves in education
last week county commissioner michael
naff directed staff to look into the
laws and regulations in the industry to
see if there is any room for improvement
crosstalk worries about the industry
there's going to have to be change and
i'm going to be at the forefront of this
because i don't want to lose my business
i worked really hard for this place he
believes more enforcement of laws could
save lives the easiest way to fix this
is to have a
you know have an inspector have have an
officer have some law enforcement person
somebody from the city attorney's office
from the county
go and pose as a renter attorney sam
marzowski says the laws are there but
more can be done to prevent the deadly
crashes these operators
should have a kill switch
it should be
obligated to maintain
monitoring active monitoring of the car
now back out here live the county
business licensing department will bring
information forward to the county for
consideration at next month's county
commission meeting and they will see if
there's any room for improvement
reporting live joe moeller live local
now